pour la troisième année consécutive le
château de buc accueille des personnes
placées sous main de justice pour des
ateliers trois hommes condamnés laissés
libres se sont retrouvés avec un auteur
le but échanger entre eux et découvrir
le monde de la bd
on est plutôt sur des personnes voilà
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de faire ce
genre d'activités qui ont peut-être pas
l'habitude non plus faire des activités
socialisante ou être dans des
associations
et puis aussi des personnes par une
mauvaise image d'elle-même
voilà est dans quelque chose de
valorisant partir du principe que
certains savent pas dessiner et au bout
de deux jours bas ils savent faire
quelque chose les participants viennent
sur la base du volontariat
à l'issue des deux jours d'ateliers une
affiche commune est réalisé dans la bd
on trouve tout c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui qui qui rassemble toutes les
générations tous les styles c'est
ludique alors on a l'impression que
juste des bulles avec des dessins mais
pas du tout il ya une recherche il ya
une vraie une vraie technique et c'est
tellement vaste c'est tellement riche
que je pense que tout le monde et trouve
son compte
cet atelier profite bien sûr aux
participants mais pas que l'auteur
encadrant aussi il trouve son compte
depuis maintenant trois ans c'est le
dessinateur et rock à qui on doit
notamment la bd les profs qui conduit
l'atelier parce que ça peut m'apporter
moi bah justement c'est de voir d'autres
gens que le public habituel de la bd
parce que on est toujours on est dans un
petit milieu un peu fermé sert les fans
de bd les enfants qui lisent mes bd que
je connais je sais ce qui leur plaît ou
pas dans mes bd dont une espèce de
ronron qui fait que là c'est différent
la joie des gens qui s'intéressent pas
forcément la bd ça et ça m'apporte déjà
des contacts différents
un atelier qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
du festival de la bd de but qu il aura
lieu les 10 et 11 octobre 2020